e aí
e ai ai já achar com eu não achei isso
como descer na praia vamos amamos o sono
e
oi oi oi oi
eu sou tanto namorar por favor fala aí
que hora é
o penteado resoluções cocos ainda ganhou
uma food festival de sabo diário sou
maria isamar um amor da mamãe eu sou eu
[Música]
sou brincalhona para morrer logo já sou
maria
o carro ai eu e abraço vai deus que a
mamãe ver o sol só eu sou marinheiro só
[Música]
a agradecer imensamente ao de leque são
paulo por essa chance compartilhar esse
frescor do mar para fazer energias novas
para todos e todos vocês uma honra essa
música é nós de marinheiro de autoria
linha e letra do guinga então muito
obrigado e que todo mundo fica
acalentado aparecer essa brisa do oceano
né é uma brisa oceano que aqui em
portugal é um pouco mais fria mas muito
obrigado a face todos e outra que são
paulo ii
e aí